can i revisit something we were talking
about just right off air and it has it
has to do with this concept of being the
best
right so you said
i was obsessed with being the best
obsessed
right and i i i come to think of uh
what's the female fight rose
there's this clip of her
um
even rogan talked about it about she's
just she's in the ring saying i'm the
best i'm the best i'm the best have you
seen her do this yes she says this i'm
the best i'm the best
you said there wasn't a lot that
separated the guy who was number two and
you were number one
physically yeah right there there's not
a lot that separates the elite athletes
physically
how much does this
mentally
being mentally prepared
everything you were talking about
earlier what separates the goat the
greatest of all time from all stars i
believe it's a lot of factor but the
reason if i think rose namajunas was
saying i'm the best i'm the best
i caught i think it's called james lance
theory and i'm gonna explain to you
we know that your mind can dictate your
body what to do if i'm thirsty i i'm
saying to myself i'm thirsty grab the
bottle and drink water
but the opposite is true too
my actions
can change
my division that i have of myself
and i use that every s before every
single of my fights
because before every fight i'm terrified
i'm extremely uncomfortable i'm scared
however
there's a routine that i have in my
locker room
and the day of the fight
my trainers know my friend knows i'm
putting on a mask i'm putting on an act
they all know i'm scared and very often
i'm telling them as i [ __ ] what the hell
i'm doing here
and they're laughing because it's the
same thing all the time the same
the same
movie that plays all the time but i'm
playing a role so they ask me even the
way i most before every fight normally i
don't have a good night of sleep because
i'm too scared i'm running scenarios in
my mind and they always ask me how uh
how fresh you feel today i'm always like
i feel great man i'm ready to kick ass
it's gonna be a good day
and i'm playing that role of a kind of a
superhero who's not afraid who's excited
to find out how he's going to win the
whole day until i meet
until it's time to take my walk to the
octagon and i have a routine that i do
when the ufc guys come and um come to
get me before i am
i walk he goes say pierre he kicked the
door he goes zeppy are you up next are
you ready i'm like yes
one minute sir i go in the bathroom
and i go in the bathroom to look myself
in the mirror and normally i before i
used to have a ghee i was putting my
gimmick back i know as i was doing this
but i'm telling myself all the reasons
why i think i will win the fight even if
it's not true
because i don't know what the other guys
does
even if it's not true as long as i
believe it
it will transform the way i see myself
and will make me more confident so i'm
telling myself that i train harder and i
put more time than he did
i have better trainers i have better
training partners i flew in all these
killers and training camp to try to test
me and i got through like a champion you
know when there's no way i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna lose this fight i'm
faster i'm i'm i have a better iq
fighting iq than he does you know i'm
stronger and for whatever the reason is
and then for one minute i telling all
this as i'm looking down and i'm putting
on an act then when i get out of the
bathroom i'm not the same person that i
was when i when i got in it's show time
and now i'm on a difference powerful i
i'm on what i call cruise control
so
that's what it that's what it is about
you know what i mean
you need to transform yourself
psychologically that's how i that's
that's what i did so when rose is i'm
the best i'm the best
that's why i think she does she's trying
to transform herself telling that
repeatedly in order to start believing
it you know who used to say that a lot
diego sanchez used to be yes yes i don't
know if you remember diego he was fun to
watch man there was something unique
about watching that guy he had a good
streak at one point and you know why
because in fighting and i think in
everything in life when you want to
achieve something that is difficult you
need to go all in
it's confidence is a very very important
thing that's why you see some guys that
are good in the gym but when they get in
when when the light comes up they can
pull the trigger confidence for me if i
can make an analogy
it's like
let's say you have someone to have all
the skills in the world but no
confidence it's like someone who has a
lot for example a lot of money in his
bank account but no way to access his
bank account so it's useless
so when you have the confidence and the
the skills now the magic can happen so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]
you